[Music]
welcome to community day at next 21 my
name is gina jorgensen and i'm here with
uzholtzei
today is unique and that it will spend
an entire 24 hours to bring together
communities from all around the world in
local time zones
but before we get into those details we
want to share some really exciting news
with you that's right but first i'd like
to thank you all for your incredible
collaboration and commitment to google
cloud because developers are really the
core inspiration behind everything that
we built
your constant pursuit of excellent
motivates us and your feedback pushes us
to be better
in a developer keynote yesterday i
announced the google cloud innovators
program with this program we want to
bring all of google cloud developers
together to co-create to learn from each
other and to unite our global technical
communities where we're supporting
google cloud and we also wanted to
reignite the human connection that many
of you have missed over the last 18
months and that can be dismissed or
overlooked in online forums
and finally we know that technical
communities can sometimes be
intimidating
to new members
and so our program's primary design
principle is grounded in inclusion and
it's serving the community regardless of
your knowledge base or your status
earned
so i want to personally invite each of
you to join us to become a google cloud
innovator so come share your experience
coach and grow others most importantly
learn from each other to build things
that have a meaningful impact on the
people who use them
terrific to join us just sign up at
cloud.google.com
innovators we're really excited to get
to know you
we also want to let you know about a
dedicated technical community event we
will host for the first time this coming
february
twice a year in different regions around
the world will bring the users and
creators of google cloud together to
brainstorm
learn and get hands-on to move projects
forward
google cloud innovators will be eligible
for invitations and speaking
opportunities early so please sign up to
be an innovator today and we'll share
more details about the event in the
coming weeks
ors we've got a few more pieces of good
news to share all right yes
uh we continue to invest heavily of
course in developer experiences through
intuitive in-product usability or
through community engagement to offer
deeper recognition of your expertise or
through access to tools and resources
that help you get your job done
and another key investment is in our
learning experiences so for example to
meet the demands of cyber security
professionals google has pledged to
train 100 000 americans in fields like
data privacy data analytics security and
i.t support and additionally
tech news world cited that over 90
percent of it leaders expect to expand
cloud services over the next one to
three years but over 80 percent
identified a lack of internal skills and
knowledge as a top barrier to cloud
success and according to another study
done by global knowledge google cloud
skills are in super high demand
commanding the top two paying it
certifications in 2021 in the us
so i'm very happy to announce google
cloud skills boost
google cloud skills boost is the
definitive destination for google cloud
learning including 700 labs courses
learning paths skills badges and
certification resources all authored by
google cloud
the platform is available globally today
in english japanese and spanish
with more languages to follow soon to
enable millions of people to build and
validate the skills that they need to
thrive in an evolving cloud first world
and finally to via firm our commitment
to accessibility of these learning
resources we are offering access at no
cost for 30 days to google cloud skills
boost so visit the website to access
free training today
fantastic okay before we get on to the
details of how community day will run
i've got two questions for you all right
okay
first question
google cloud has been talking about
empathetic engineering for quite some
time now can you tell us a little bit
more about what that means and why you
think it strengthens developer
experiences sure by empathetic
engineering we really mean
how are we putting ourselves in the
shoes of our users the developers and
ensure that we build products and
services that really start with your
needs first
we've always been an engineering led
company so what we needed to learn was
really how you wanted to use our
services because
users come with different challenges and
different backgrounds from different
industries you know some of them new to
cloud technologies so that's where
customer empathy comes in as an engineer
do you really understand the experience
that real users have with your products
are you really walking in their shoes
so we implemented a listening and
learning system based on customer
empathy for example
teams test products by performing
common user journeys at just the same
way customers would without internal
help without internal tools without
insider tips we gather the feedback we
improve the services or the
documentation and then test it with real
customers so we keep iterating until
we're confident that we've built
intuitive services that are easy for
developers to implement and build great
solutions around
great thank you for that so here's my
second question for you if you were
starting your career in technology today
where would you focus your learning well
that's a huge question
because technology evolves so quickly
that
it can be pretty overwhelming especially
if you're early in your career and
unfortunately that because of the
digital transformation of many
industries the success
of those organizations will increasingly
depend on the services and products that
are built by its developers so learning
really is super important
based on what i've seen i would uh
probably start with these three things
first you have to dedicate time for
learning every single week right so i'd
start out
be by determining what forms of learning
work uh for you
uh independently of the subject and then
really allocate a set of hours to grow
your knowledge base right so for some
reading works best for some it's videos
for some it's interactive events you
just gotta understand what works out for
you
and so next i will pick a couple of
topic areas that really interest you and
start learning the fundamentals uh
joining online communities or forums uh
can be a really good way uh to to get
different perspectives on a subject that
maybe aren't in the in the standard
traditional learning paths
and then finally of course the question
is well what subjects should you go
after um now there's hundreds of them
and and so that's really something that
depends on you and your preferences and
your situation but but i'd say three
errors kind of come to mind for me first
uh customer empathy i already talked
about it it's not something that's
taught in schools but it's really really
important
that we build technology that people
actually want to use right and so when
design a product and you start with a
deep understanding of what the customer
actually needs then you can really build
more than just the solution you can
create a viable business and a viable
product that really lasts second
learning what it
takes to ship a product uh also not
broadly taught in schools is really
invaluable in almost every job that i've
seen so
that includes things like the
fundamentals of release processes
lean or agile development and how you
best design products for for
self-service delivery because
you want to design your products such
that users can start using it quickly
rather than
depend on some complicated
instructions or or deployment process
and then last but not least
security right you've all heard about
the growing cyber threats that so many
organizations are facing and they're
only going to get more sophisticated and
more invasive and so security is
something that you need to build into
your product and in your development
process from the beginning you can't
bolt it on later so learn about the
fundamentals of securing a product or
system and then keep up with the trends
so that will
give you the the confidence that you
need
to build the long-term viable products
or companies
right really really great advice thank
you for that i know it'll be especially
important for new developers and early
and career folks so thank you
i mentioned earlier that i'd give you a
quick rundown of community today and how
it will unfold so let's do that now
right after this there is a special
spotlight session featuring jim hogan a
healthcare strategist in google cloud
alongside vince cerf the co-creator of
tcpip and who has often been coined the
father of the internet
the two will have a candid conversation
about accessibility in the workplace we
think it's going to be a great session
and we really really are excited to have
you join us
after that we'll head into the heart of
community day
you can join us in an immersive
gathering experience called kumo space
which creates virtual campus with
meeting rooms smaller spaces to hang out
for one-on-one conversations and then
larger auditoriums for more common
topics
every single part of the day will be
powered by google cloud including kumo
space
so the day kicks off with conversations
led by google developer groups across
europe middle east and india
and then the rest of the day will have a
variety of experiences and community
gatherings with a few topics available
at each time block the first time
blocked you can attend discussions led
by googlers and community members like
our google developer experts and expert
innovators dedicated to specific
technologies like vertex ai secure
software supply chain flutter or
workspace and then the second block you
can follow a specific community pathway
and spend time with specialized groups
like kaggle data scientists or women
tech makers or even region specific
groups and the third and final track
throughout the day will have a dedicated
spaces for learning
how you can earn a cloud certification
develop new skills and hands-on lab
sessions or even apply your skills for
good and philanthropic related
competition with other attendees
we really look forward to seeing you and
hope you enjoy the rest of the event
join us next for the dei spotlight
session with jim and vint thank you so
much for spending the last few days with
us remember to sign up for google cloud
innovators and become part of our google
developer family we're excited to get to
know you and spend more time with you in
the future enjoy the rest of next
you